this is a production of Cornell
University
alright let me tell you a little bit
about some of the things that are going
on in the industry who here thinks the
industry is anything like it was in 2007
I think we all know it's changed quite a
bit
first of all the recession had a huge
impact we all know that generally
speaking our industry is somewhat immune
to recessions people still own their
homes people still want to invest in
their homes they may cancel going out
the dinner or a nicer vacation but they
continue investing in their homes this
one was different I think we all know
why I'm not gonna dwell too long on this
but with so many people losing their
homes our industry was deeply impacted
there's no new buildings you know going
up there's no new homes going up and
therefore the the demand for four
planets we're starting to die off and I
would say a good number of people went
out of business in that time period also
garden retailers are retiring in huge
numbers you know I don't know what was
going on in the 70s and 80s but it was
like a baby boom for garden retail how
many people in here are garden retailers
are a handful of you how many here less
than 55 years old to own a garden center
who own a garden center so we have one
so it's you know if you if you're
serving garden retail or if you someone
who owned it yourself the ownership is
going through a huge huge change because
everybody wants to retire consumers are
changing and that's no big secret there
at all and I'm gonna go into each one of
these little bit more deeply here in a
moment and sorry guys
plant retool is moving away from the
term garden centers the word gardening
is beginning to not be all that popular
all right so owners are retiring so what
happens when they retire about a third
of them have family members or employees
who are buying or inheriting the
business hopefully you're selling the
business and the land in order to sell
the business and this is kind of this is
where the timing is really
really poor with the 2008 recession if
you were not making a profit for the
last three years it's very difficult to
sell your business you know that you're
selling the inventory and you're selling
the land you're sitting on so hopefully
these people have been able to turn it
around before they retire and able to
sell the business all right so if you
are selling you're if you're not able to
sell your business hopefully you're able
to sell the land if you own the land if
you're not leasing it if you sell the
land and the inventory if you don't have
a profit and you work until you can't
anymore that's your other option if you
can't sell anything a lot of retailers I
know who are looking to retire they have
like a five year selling plan they go
ahead and quietly put their business up
for sale so they could have several
years to sell it it's not like selling a
house it's a very different business so
if you were supplying plants to people
who have a retail business keep that in
mind because that's a very different
mindset for those who are you know
they're not necessarily reinvesting in
their company unless they're trying to
sell it or they have someone else to
pass it on to so that's gonna be a
challenge for you now at the same time
garden plant retail is not just plant
retail anymore I'm trying to get us out
of my hands here moment it's not gonna
be pretty but there we go
all right so it's not just plant retail
anymore a lot of retailers are going at
this having services and this isn't just
landscape I'm not talking about the
traditional landscape services I'm
talking about going to a customer's home
and doing a sketch of a layout for them
so landscape extremely light or it might
be going in and changing out patio pots
for them or putting up Christmas
decorations their product mix is
changing the types of plants that
they're selling you know obviously
annuals are still keen but we checked
that every year we asked retailers about
how their plant cells are going and
annuals and perennials are still keen
but shrubs and trees and the large
perennials and a
those things have been quiet this year's
different this year's different we've
been hearing good news about the larger
plants but for the past several years
they've been going down and fitting
garden is are blending I know a lot of
retailers who are actually starting to
host farmers markets at their center
they're either giving space to people
who have farmers markets or they're
actually becoming the farmer market farm
market managers for it or they're
hosting CSAs and they're also selling a
lot of food plants and edibles and also
produce themselves so you're beginning
to see kind of the spin of the farm
market and the garden center and this is
happening more on the garden retail side
than it is on the farm market side
you're not seeing as many plants going
in the farm markets as you are produce
going in the farm type greenhouse garden
centers and the beginning act as
community hub you know they have
especially in the wintertime when they
have all that space underneath the
greenhouse I'm seeing more and more
garden centers that either leasing or
donating the space they have so this is
where the Lions Club meets and this is
where sometimes Town Council's have
their meetings where they have community
get together see there's a lot of
auctions that begin happening so that
they're able to use that space when it's
not having that full of plants all of
these things are going to impact how how
we're selling plants you could see the
traditional model of what we're doing
isn't at all what it used to be and
they're setting up shop where consumers
are so your spaghetti meseta pop-ups
that are coming around but they aren't
just on the corner of a busy street
anymore you're seeing them in the
farmers markets you're seeing them like
a little stand outside the popular craft
beer you know location and that type of
thing you're beginning to see them at
festivals so where consumers are is
drawing retail there that's a very small
footprint generally speaking all right
so consumers are changing let me give
you a little background here on this
section here who's here is tired of
hearing about Millennials and how they
behave too bad
I have been working with Bridget Beatty
with Michigan State
and Susan Hogan with Emory University
well she was with Emory University a
year ago she got lured away by deloitte
and touche over very big salary but for
the past three years since 2013 we have
been doing consumer research and what we
wanted to know well what we really
wanted to do is only slightly ambitious
we want to figure out how we can expand
the number of people who garden not at
all ambitious and so what we started
looking at we wanted to know what are
the barriers we wanted to find out why
what people think about garden centers
what do they think about gardening but I
don't think about plants and their own
yards and their lifestyles and then we
also wanted to figure out what kind of
marketing messages so stage two was to
go to the PR type people in the
advertising firms and in stage three was
then to recruit real-world garden
centers to implement these marketing
messages and see how they went so what I
want to go over here is going to be
about the research we've done and what
we found out we decided to look at those
who are under 50 for our research or a
very good reason
ruby has been looking at consumers for a
long time those who are over 50 if
they're not gardening they have a very
good reason why they're not gardening
anymore they've moved into a condo
they've tried it they hate it you know
they're not gonna be able to convert
that group as much so our goal was to
expand people who garden which means we
need to get those who are more ignorant
about gardening or have not tried it or
just beginning to to think about it so
that's why we chose this group so what
we did is we had we did focus groups and
we've done this in three different
locations one was in Atlanta one was in
Ohio and right now we're working in the
Toronto area and we've been working with
in Ohio and Toronto we worked with two
different grants along with that as well
flowers Canada than the USDA that the
Department of Ag in Ohio so we had three
days of focus groups where we had those
we wanted to find out what the pipeline
was doing these are not the people we
necessarily think are going to be our
customers right now but we looked at the
18 to 29 year olds we then looked at the
32 Ford
49 year olds which is our sweet spot and
then we also looked at parents who had
children between the ages of two and
twelve because that's a whole different
dynamic all on its own and we had three
days of questions for each of those
groups and we wanted at least 20
participants in each group which means
if he wanted them there by the third day
you start at the first day with you know
a lot more so on average we had more
than a hundred people on each year of
study so here are some of the things we
found so this is the first this is
Ohio's key findings we find out that the
act of gardening has mostly positive
impression of so I'm starting positive
here you know they think of it it's
outdoors and beautiful and healthy and
and so we do have that reputation good
news consumers have distinct ideas of
who gardens and it's that lady right
there and they don't see themselves at
that lady right there they think she has
to have tons of time and here's a very
key part she has to be expert she has to
know what she's doing and even people
who like the garden think that are
stupid about it they don't feel expert
so that's a problem and it's a very
limit that limiting them they're not
going to associate themselves with that
hobby and that's where the term
gardening has a problem garden centers
are the third most popular place to buy
plants grocery stores and mass merchants
are the most popular and they will drive
pie a independent and what was
interesting the first time we did a
focus group was in Atlanta where Home
Depot is headquartered and what we were
being told is that if you go into a
garden retail somebody who's an expert
in that it's intimidating I don't want
to feel stupid if I go in there and they
know more than I did and they know I
know more like me they know more than I
do then I feel humiliated there's a
sense of being caught being stupid and
nobody wants to feel that way so they
would rather go to Home Depot where they
know the employees might or might not
know but at least they're not stupid in
comparison to them so
yeah that's something we have to
overcome that's a barrier and consumers
lack this this one was really
interesting this fourth finding you know
we had the three days of questions
that's a lot of questions we're asking
we didn't ask one question in this field
this became a queue fiving because we
heard the word luck and risk over and
over and over again from every all three
groups and related to all these
different questions over three days so
like one person said I knew I shouldn't
buy that rose those so beautiful I knew
was gonna kill it but I bought it anyway
and I was so lucky it survived you know
it's just there's a sense that if you
buy a plant you have no impact on if it
succeeds if it lives or dies it's almost
like they're expecting that you know
like I think of gardening and like
someone going to cook and have it don't
have a recipe and they decided to throw
out a thing into a pot and hope it comes
out tasty you know that they're so since
that we don't need recipes so you know
there's a sense we have no control over
how it happens and so you know we that's
that's a major problem that's why
gardening is not the number one hobby
anymore you know so that that's a big
one this is what we learned last year in
this past year it's uncomfortable
feeling ignorant which is not the two
different groups these are two totally
different you know once in a high Oh
ones in Canada and we also had the ones
in Atlanta we heard this again and again
yes yes
yeah I think that's incredibly
insightful he's saying just for those of
you who didn't hear and he wonders if
two three and four is that right or two
and three two and three are interrelated
so they have a distinct idea who gardens
and then Gardens there I think it is
very much that basically I had several
people tell me in Atlanta because those
are the ones I actually sat in and not
the other ones we we made sure we
weren't in the room other than to
moderate questions you know people come
to us so we're trying to make sure it's
as unintimidating a process as possible
but I heard several people say that I
will go to a garden center once I'm an
expert but I'm not an expert yet so yeah
you're gonna follow up a question
yeah everybody familiar with the
Brandeis I think it's Brandeis isn't it
that does the incoming freshmen kind of
their world perspective right right
suppose say they've never been in a
world where you know I don't know what
the most recent stuff yeah they've
always had I have always had smartphones
they don't know what a CD is you know
they you know they've never been heard
of a beat VCRs they kind of go through
to try to get the professor's a sense of
the kind of world perspective well think
about that when it comes to gardening
you know my grandparents were major
gardeners I was lucky enough that my mom
left the garden but most people most
people do not have parent to garden
there are at least two generations away
and I'm fifty by the way so I'm on that
cusp of between these these two groups
so you get younger and younger
generations there's the whole disconnect
of how they what gardening is and and
that type of thing there's another
problem which I'm not to get to in a
moment here no one wants to feel
ignorant and if they feel ignorant
they're not you know there's a sense of
they're not going to even try which
leads to online research it's a big deal
and this is funny someone that dinner
last night was talking about this
they're saying that you know people will
come into the gardens nursing I'm so
confused I try to looked it up online
they may ever try to research things
online and I'm someone who I'm a new
homeowner I've had a house for a year
and the element and my oven caught on
fire shorted out and you by the way
usual ways of putting out a fighter
doesn't work other than this turning off
the oven so I went online to find out
some cheap and I want to do an addition
a little bit have a new kitchen I don't
want to buy a new oven so I went online
and I saw a video on how to replace the
element that's what people do now you
know but try to do that with gardening
it's not as easy I mean there's there's
and we're getting better and better
there's more out there than there used
to be but there's a lot of information
and this information and it's confusing
so what they'll do the start online but
they want to trust a real world person
that could be
their aunt or they do know someone in
the family who garden so they'll call
them up now or they'll go into a garden
center now and start asking questions
okay so yes online research is extremely
important that's where they start but
then they kind of get so far then they
want to talk to someone who they think
might know what they're talking about
and that's where we have a real
opportunity in food gardening is almost
as common as flower gardening involved
woman is a consultant in the industry
and he's been working with the national
gardening Association with international
survey they've been doing they've been
doing it since I think 1970 and they
look at food gardening not just for the
vegetable plants and the herbs which we
know are not very high ticket or high
margin products they look at everything
else that people buy when they do that
type of gardening which is a lot of
stuff they want to have you know as you
mentioned you have people who want to do
vegetable gardens in containers you know
so they're buying all of that garden
media they're buying the pots which are
usually big pots because if you have a
tomato you can't have a little pot you
know so they're they're buying gloves
and all these things you know they want
me this generation wants to look the
part so they're gonna get their boots
and their clogs in there you know
they're gonna get the hats everything
they're gonna be they're gonna be
well-equipped that's a lot of money and
that's more associated with vegetable
gardening than it is with flower
gardening now it hasn't completely
overtaken it but it's neck-and-neck so
don't underestimate that that category
for yourself
we've got a real problem think about
when we have dinner parties what do
people gather now kitchen island you
know they used to be out in the dining
room or if you had them outdoors you
know when he had big big parties
- are they held in the backyard anymore
they're almost always held inside now
you know because we don't want
mosquitoes we don't want the heat we
don't want the rain you know only if the
conditions are absolutely perfect and
you had time to mow the grass and do the
weeding and all that do you see what I
mean that's all chores think about all
of the you know one of the you think
about how popular an HDTV is you know
all the home decor stuff is because
people are inside all the time and
they're looking going you know I'm kind
of tired of the cut you know I think I
need to restain that wall because you're
looking at it all the time
and you begin thinking I don't like that
blonde wood anymore I want it to look a
little I want to get a little pop you
begin you know that's just human nature
you want to begin tweaking stuff if
you're not outside they're not thinking
that way if the only time you're going
outside is the snow blow or you're going
out to rake are you going out to mow the
lawn it's annoying and if you're only
going outside to get in your car we've
got a problem people want to be outside
don't get me wrong but they're going to
hiking trails they're going to the beach
the goings out don't you know they're
kids sporting events outdoors some
people now are not their backyard so
we've got to figure out in our marketing
you know your the nature is at your
doorstep you know we need to emphasize
that nature is right there because the
people are not going outside all they're
doing our chores you know has anyone
ever had done any home renovations do
you know how freaking hard that is I
mean my best friend and I decided she
had this cute bungalow and they decided
to get a big attic and they're gonna add
a bedroom up there so we took out the
hall closet and I know it's all the rage
now but shift laughs if you ever try to
actually pull that sucker stop that
stuff off it was so much fun for like
the first 15 minutes
we had about four more days to go so but
people are still focused on the end
result gardening is nowhere near as hard
as home decor but we're so focused on
the annoying part you know they're not
looking at the end result because
they're not outside enjoying it and this
is the fun part
this is the part I like so much people
who absolutely hated gardening who had
no desire was never going to do it 100%
every single person said children should
be gardening they need to get unplugged
they need to get away from all their
computers and their games they need to
understand where food comes from it's
educational
everybody thinks kids should be
gardening yeah that I think it's big
vehicle to get people back into the
garden retail in the plant cells when
you think about what you know this
desire to get unplugged and get out of
all the routine because gardening is not
as routine and I say going to a sporting
event and on ballet and everything is so
so structured and people aren't quite
ready to give that up because they still
want him to get into Cornell and Harvard
and that type of thing but they do want
them to have a little bit more
instructor time but has to be
educational it has to be productive so
really think about the marketing that
you can be doing I remember I wrote an
article a few years and this would not
make sense at all today and it wasn't
that long ago it's less than five years
ago and the question was do we really
want to have kids in the garden center
because a lot of retailers don't want
kids coming to the garden center all
they do is they what they force the
parents to be there for less than 20
minutes their attention span is so short
they mess things up they climb on a stop
and and and their parents never spend
that much anyway which actually I'll
show you a little bit they do but if you
don't bring the kids you're not gonna
have cells pretty quickly and this is
where you get the adults in because
everybody thinks kids need to be in
there
now with a cover story you know I don't
know if you guys heard that she's saying
there's a garden center near her her
that has a scavenger hunt for kids and
they have to go through the store and
when they they find their tomato plant
or whatever it is the prize that they
get they get a gold star when they leave
so that's awesome all right now think
about that mindset and think about what
they would think walking into this we've
got a perception problem you walk in and
it's a horizontal sea of green it's
intimidating I don't know what even the
difference between the annual and a
perennial and I'm walking into this I
mean this is actually pretty well done I
think this you know it's attractive but
if I have someone who doesn't know where
to get started
yikes I'm scared how are we doing on
time by the way cuz I'm kind of okay
good alright so there is a solution all
this I'm not someone who's to say scared
scared scared I'm very much you've got
to be able to figure out what we can do
about it so my philosophy for like my
career is if I focus on who is reading
who is the audience we can't go too far
wrong you know we're gonna follow them
we might go make a misstep here or there
but if we get so stuck on ourselves
thinking we know everything we're going
to not where our numbers of people who
are reading articles and I think we're
just gonna plumb it we're gonna crash
and burn the exact same thing is true
for anyone who deals with the public
including garden centers you know we
have to be thinking about who your
customer is and some of the things we've
done you know one of the reasons we've
been so specific about the locations is
you have to understand the customer in
that location they aren't the same in
Toronto as they are in Atlanta Georgia
now there's some universal truths about
human nature your community
as your community and so we worked with
I work with Susan Hogan she was the
professor from the NB a college boys
etta School of Business I think it's
called at Emory University in Atlanta
and we worked with a garden center in
Massachusetts called Lakeview nurseries
anybody familiar with Lakeview they've
got a couple of locations in lüneburg
arena and that's the staff they're a fun
bunch and so we did this in May of 2012
April and May and we decided we're going
to research her customers specifically
those who are actually coming in to the
garden center so we're looking at
customers here and she's going oh and I
already know my customers I'm there
every day and I'm reading all the new
reports that come out and she is a very
smart woman you know I'm see if I could
see Michele Michele it's a second from
the end there I'm sure there's some way
to do a pointer here that's not it I'm
not gonna play with this other than the
four and a backward now there we go
that's Michele right there Michele
Harvey and she owns it and that's her
husband her family owned it and that's
her husband who's the finance guy on the
on this team so it's important to know
what Richard Burr his name is Richard
birch he was a skeptic on all of the
stuff we're doing beforehand so she was
sure she understood cuz she's someone
who really pays attention she does a lot
of really smart things though he said
let's just take a look at who your
customers are so going in she knew who
our customer was she was a 50 to 60
something female and she was affluent
and she loved gardening so we decided to
do three different types of research
methods how many people in here are
researchers okay I'm gonna be going over
stuff you've heard so we did the
observational which I call the jane
goodall or more honestly stalking
laddering which is answering questions
and asking basically like a
three-year-old why Wi-Fi by Wi-Fi until
you're getting to the emotional payoff
of what caused something fairly normal I
could know that in a second OOP when it
jumps forward it jumps forward and then
we did a survey so we went to watching
what they're doing then hyper individual
and then we went to as broad as we could
so we did three different methods to try
to figure it out the observational
method you have to recruit people so you
basically what they're doing is they are
watching people shop and they're taking
notes and so you have to find the right
person rule number one never have it be
a male ever because and this is
stereotyping but women we most of us
were raised to always be aware of who's
around us and males or threats unless
he's a really cute guy but you're
noticing him too so generally speaking
if you don't know a guy and you know if
someone just happens to be going from
department department with you you're
always aware of that I'm know I'm
generalizing but if anyone every any
female in here think differently on that
one generally I mean it's true enough
that enough women are doing this that we
are aware were you know I don't know
about you I was always taught to look in
the backseat before I get in the car so
that first episode of Dexter when he
strangled a guy in the front you know by
jumping on the back seat it's like yeah
that never would have happened with a
woman you know we always look in the
backseat we're always aware of the fact
that we could be easy victims because
we're not as physically strong as men
you know we're not I'm not saying we're
always victims but we're always alert so
you never want to have a male do it so
what they ended up doing is they
recruited two ladies who head up their
garden clubs in the area and they shop
at multiple stores so they did not want
them to be employees that's another big
important role your employees are
recognized and people are going to
they're gonna be interrupted they're
gonna be they're gonna be noticed as
well so they got two older ladies who
shop at multiple stores who are gonna be
a little bit more fair they're not
say how incredible you are that type of
thing and they worked separately and
they follow people all day long two days
on it you know Saturday and Sunday two
weekends in a row they wanted to they
selected the criteria but they're going
to observe they had bought new they're
on a hilly location so they had bought
hand brakes on their carts and they
wanted to see you know basically I'm
sure they're looking at Hey look how
much more money we're getting because of
these great carts we have now we're not
having to go down to the liquor store at
the bottom of the hill to get our carts
back but they also wanted to see if
we're in the store they went how many
people they talked to what you know
which departments they went to they pick
things up and put them back down what
they end up buying did they do think you
know didn't have impulse buy they're
also looking at general they can
guesstimate their age they could you
know they're by themselves or they're
with kids who are a friend or spouse you
know they're making this type of
observations and how long they were in
the store they did it for multiple days
of observation and they compiled the
chart and the results in a chart so a
chart sample time in store we've kind of
gone the age and gender behavior and
they took note so they had room if
there's something unusual they can make
a note about that so here's an example
of what we learned here so we had this
person number one is there in the store
35 minutes there were about in 30s
there's a female with one child primary
path they really wanted to see where
they win it so we have the path there
she spoke with staff yes
what were they what was purchase window
boxes kid project hummingbird feeder and
perennials add-ons at checkout she got
that hummingbird hummingbird feeder
right there and they seemed to pick up
an item from every department staff
worked with her to find plants and so on
so they did this with everybody and what
they found out sorry
so what they found out when they
compiled all of this their main customer
was a 30-something couple they were in a
store about 20 minutes on average you
know she was a little bit above average
in her time there and she actually spoke
with a lot of people generally speaking
they didn't speak to people in their
departments they were there quickly
because they had kids there there like I
said that 20-minute time for him but
they piled a lot of stuff in that short
time period now the next most important
group was that 50 something female but
they were there on average 45 minutes
and they spoke with people in there to
each department that makes a big
difference in how your marketing so the
next one and we're short on time I would
normally bring someone up here with us
say hey let's do a practice of laddering
but this is kind of a why-why-why method
so if you can have about half hour of
the per customer what you do is you ask
them what is the last thing you
purchased so what's the last thing you
purchased at a garden center a perennial
and why did you buy that perennial why
did you want it
okay so why is it important to you to
have something that appeals to you
that's different I don't know he caught
that she was told that this is not zone
six I don't think I should sell it to
you if you go now I need to have it he
was right
it died but generally keep pushing and
pushing and pushing until you find out
what is the emotional payoff so for one
woman that this method was done they
found out that she actually doesn't like
gardening but she wants her daughter to
come over and spend time with her and so
she that's her daughter will come over
to garden that's one of the tasks her
daughter volunteers its happy to do with
her because mom needs help in the are so
she doesn't really like gardening but
it's a way to spend time with her
daughter the emotional payoff has
nothing to do with that plant it has to
do with family and emotional fulfillment
someone else and this is where it gets
interesting so when you're interviewing
all these individuals and then you go
back to the other one and you kind of
compare notes about the different groups
the thirtysomething is I'm the kind of
person who really cares about the planet
and I'm going to be an organic gardener
I'm the kind of person who cares about
what happens to the food that goes in my
family's body so I want to make sure
it's pure I have all control over that
I'm the kind of person to see the you
know the continued here all of it was
about a form of self-expression that's
extremely different than somewhat like
the older group it was more about a
chance to be alone the younger group was
about socializing the older group was
about recharging and getting away from
the madness of their of their life those
are two extremely different marketing
messages so you really need to
understand the demographics of who's
buying the plants in your area in your
store how my time
hmm ten minutes okay so it's all saying
if you notice patterns in the in the
observational study the nican apply you
can cross match it here we also did the
survey method and frankly this was
almost just like a checking how are we
doing so we asked what do you want from
a garden center and they had a whole
bunch of things they could choose from
and then they asked specifically how do
we do each of them and that went to
several thousand people so you could see
you know what we're we're looking at
different areas so here's some of the
questions we asked you know what's
important to you then how are we doing
on that
well it change from group to group so
again we got the demographic information
so it was important to have when it
comes to independent this is true across
the board with people who cared about
knowledge who cared about quality they
always went to a local locally owned
plant retailer
it was convenience of course it's going
to be the grocery store or a master
tickets they're never there just to buy
plants usually they're there to buy
other things as well and I can say
someone is you know as busy as I am
that's a big appeal you know so being
active in the community kid friendly you
can see where that all different all
these different things would be variety
of plants was important but it's not as
important as we as retailers Timothy you
know we are plant people not business
people so we put you know the plant is
most important it is our biggest you
know everybody knows it's our biggest
seller if you look at all plants as a
whole so we need to increase the cells
of that and that's why they're there at
your store but we tend to put much more
you know we will give you six ways to
kill a slug we'll give you 20,000 Rose
varieties and the consumer wants us to
actually do some editing for them on
that I think so and that's not part of
the study that's just me editorializing
so all right so what leaf you learned
this primary customer family with the
parents in their 30s or 40s the
expensive cars for her bust Michelle
kept the diary through all of this it
was hilarious and people because he had
it was you know like with a lawn mower
we have a double handle in order for it
to go you have to squeeze it together
and the stop it you let go the same kind
of concept people couldn't figure that
out they were dragging specially the
guys we're dragging it through the
gravel with the brakes on
so they had a fire sale pretty quickly
after that there are $500 a piece yeah
she had to submit that they made a
mistake with it the customers were
ditching the racetrack path okay for
anyone who doesn't know what a racetrack
path is it's whenever you have I could
go through IKEA they have a racetrack
they take you through the entire store
and you kind of have to know the inside
ways to kind of cut corners that's the
same concept with the garden center we
take there's a wider path than anything
else in the garden center and it takes
you all the way through all the plant
yard and throughout the entire store so
they have one here because the further
they go into the store the more they're
going to buy so they were finding that
there's one location where everybody was
leaving on the first weekend so the next
weekend in between the week between the
two weekends they increase the size of
the display there so they didn't block
it if they actually wanted to be there
but it wasn't so visually appealing you
know what's at this wider path so they
made it so they can go in that section
easily but it wasn't so obvious a path
and everybody started going to the back
of the store after that so it worked so
this is just a good practice overall now
these are things beyond just you know
this is just behavior the customer they
also found out that what motivates the
two main customer groups are very
different and sales training needed
tweaking this is really interesting
they had a product that they're not
making money on it's a five dollar
starter kit for every shrub sold they
want their staff to sell this five
dollar starter kit everything then there
is value I mean that's whole so it is no
margin on that at all it's
straightforward but they do that because
just by the customer reading the
instructions putting in the fertilizer
they're watering the plant more just the
fact that they're you know taking care
they're not just putting it in the
ground and walking away they have more
success and there's nothing more
discouraging there's someone had the
first plant they buy especially they
spend money on it like a shrub but for
it to die and so they found out their
staff wasn't doing that weren't really
selling that starter kit so they had an
emergency staff meeting where they did
role playing and different things like
that
their staff and their cells on that
starter kit went up 65% like I said the
cells of the starter kit itself
monetarily aren't that important but it
is because then the customer has more
success and they're happy and they'll
come back to the store yes
you know that's that would have been
brilliant what she's saying is that it
probably would have been smarter and you
need to quite say it that way but that I
probably have been smarter to add the
cost of the starter kit to the shrubs so
they could it as a gift with purchase
you know we want you to succeed so much
here's here's our gift to you making
sure there could their costs are covered
because they're not you know this is not
a money-making venture for them that's
that's a brilliant idea
and that's important that you actually
add the price right now and another
study I'm working on right now it's
pricing and we are terrible about
including all our costs when we put
plants in Chrysler plant both growers
and retailers or terrible at it
Freight is a cost and it's not a bad
thing to include it in the cost you're
not cheating your customer because
you're wanting to include Freight in
your cost sorry you can tell a lot of
people do not do that so alright so I'm
private it because we're probably
towards the end here right five minutes
okay so
you can saw I'm not wearing a watch so
thank you I appreciate that so that was
like looking at your own own store the
other thing is how do we get bigger
Pinot Noir people to come into your
store and you need to get comfortable
with spending time with a census because
the census will have information
demographic information about the zip
codes in your community I mean you can
get really granular with what the
information the US government has and
you can target communities that you know
you want to be attracting so you you
know you can send all of your mailers to
that zip code and that type of thing
there's a lot you can learn from that
and hold focus groups you know $500 gift
cards and put an ad on Craigslist to get
people to come in and begin questioning
them about you could choose what area
that it is that you want to improve if
you're wanting to do projects that you
want to have displays related to that
what are the projects they're trying to
want to do at their home what are they
trying to improve you know there's a lot
of different things create an advisory
panel I do that for myself I've done
that to the beginning my career I will
you know if I have something come up I
have a group of people who've agreed to
let me bug them on the phone and say hey
I've got this topic I think we need a
handle but I I'm not doing what you're
doing what should I do with it
you can do the same thing with customers
you know get a group that you know will
be honest and you need to pick the
people right you want people who are
opinionated but not people who are
obnoxious and arts are so opinionated
that they can't see how that people have
different points of view you know so you
don't you know you want someone who's
going to be honest and this shoots from
the hip and tell you tell you what you
need to hear and you can get some really
good information and I would say bring
them together at least once a month to
kind of get some feedback take them to
dinner this is not a focus group this is
not something formal this is you you
know being willing to hear people who
are willing to help you out
there's an HOA offer to work together
HOAs have an amazing amount of power the
business home owners associations for
those who don't know what that is and
they have rules like oh if you let the
grass go Brown you get fined every day
it's brown you know I'm from Texas so
you know there's actually people out
there spray-painting they're from their
lawn to get brown that you cannot have
more than three rose bushes in your yard
you know there's a lot of people people
who get on HOA boards and if anybody in
here is on one I'm about to insult you a
lot of people get on HOA Bart boards are
people who are not accustomed to having
power in their lives so they kind of go
a little crazy when I was in college I
worked with the Student Loan Association
in the summer I don't know why they did
this but they asked me to organize the
annual homeless
what do you call it the conference I'm a
college student I don't know what the
heck I'm doing but I'm lining up the
speaker's you know they're getting me
the speakers but I'm calling them and
I'm biting them and I'm doing the site
visits and I mean this is way more power
than I should have been given but I was
also moonlighting at night at Dillard's
and so one day I had to speak to the
Secretary of Education for the United
States get him on the phone with mr.
secretary oh no no call me Bill you know
very very nice I get to work that night
it's just little guy who's the manager
of the store I am he's like maybe five
years older than me I'm mr. Monroe you
must call me Monroe mr. Monroe like okay
people with not much power have more
desire to force other people to show
them respect people with real powered
need to do it
HOA sometimes you get that mindset on
those boards I think every yard in this
should never ever ever ever have a pink
flamingo and if you haven't I'm fining
you $1,000 you know we could only have
blue and green at the front door colors
you know you can only have wrought iron
for your fence there's some silly stuff
it happens with plants too you can't
have any vegetable plants in your yarn
at all it's tacky you know so if you
actually work with homeowners
association I've known a couple
retailers who've done this
they'll have open nights that there
garden center where 10% of all sales or
that's a big not just profit potential
omona association they love getting
money so if you work with them and then
you can say hey there's some here's some
things you should know about
sustainability and this is what you know
can really help your community and you
you can work with them it's being partly
- playing paulo politics really is what
it is
but it can make a big difference so this
will set us talking about fact finder
com go spend some time and explore your
community I mean you need to find out
what the ethnic groups are in your
community we're far to fight an industry
and we attract far too many white people
or a much more diverse country than that
and we need to figure out and again that
focus groups advisers all of that be
respectful try to find out you know how
gardening is different for someone you
know if you have a large community that
has emigrated from Estonia you know that
that's the way America is today we have
enclaves from countries sometimes we've
never heard of until we find out that's
part of our community we need to be
reaching out to these communities
America's only get any more diverse it's
been time here and that's going to help
you get to know your community so good
news is we're an industry made up of
independently owned businesses and that
means we are more flexible we're better
able to understand who our communities
are and if we really focus on who they
are all of those problems I was talking
about in the beginning we're all there's
no one answer there's no one answer but
if you're focusing so much on who your
customer is you're going to be
responding to them and you're going to
be automatically appealing to them
because of that so thank you very much I
appreciate your time
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu